buenos días hoy es un día de mucho
entusiasmo en khan academy porque vamos
a empezar una nueva sección una nueva
serie y lo que voy a hacer es trabajar
un montón en problemas del sat del s
en la forma de preparación libre del sat
al igual que otras páginas en línea es
una página gratuita que se dedica a
preparar en diversas temas a estudiantes
que quieran regularizarse en alguna
materia o tengan próximo un examen de
admisión o vayan a presentar
próximamente un examen escolar en estos
vídeos no voy a basar en el libro que
voy a poner justo aquí el cual sería muy
bueno que pudieran comprar o conseguir
una versión en pdf o al menos pedir
prestado o sacado de alguna biblioteca
el libro se llama sad una guía de
estudio oficial y en verdad espero que
no está haciendo ningún tipo de
infracción en los derechos de autor no
soy abogado y espero que no esté
cometiendo un delito sobre los derechos
de autor por eso quiero decir
exactamente de que el libro está sacando
estos problemas y enseñarlo para que se
vea bien y lo compren
espero que diciéndoles que todos los
problemas de esta serie
a sacar este libro y además que le voy a
dar todo el crédito a los autores de
este libro y que esto lo voy a trabajar
en la solución de sus problemas
espero no esté haciendo algo malo pero
bueno de cualquier manera mi idea es que
en cada día o bueno tal vez no cada día
pero muy seguido voy a trabajar en los
problemas la sección de matemáticas de
este libro
espero poder resolver todos los
problemas de matemáticas que tiene el
libro así que lo mejor que podrías hacer
para prepararte para un examen de
admisión es conseguir el libro ir a la
sección de matemáticas y resolver todos
los problemas por ti mismo para así
obtener tu puntaje y después comparar
tus respuestas con estos vídeos de khan
academy darte cuenta de tus errores y
además con estos vídeos vas a poder
encontrar una forma de resolver los
problemas que no pudiste resolver así
que una vez dicho todo esto voy a usar
este libro de aquí es la guía de estudio
oficial del sat ese tema y empezaremos
en la página 395 estamos la sección 3 de
la parte de matemáticas y bueno hay
veces que escribiré el problema completo
otras veces
por cuestiones de tiempo no es decir que
voy a asumir que tú tienes el texto y si
puedes conseguirlo pero no por ello no
anotar todos los datos más importantes
de cada problema una vez dicho esto
manos a la obra
problema número 1
dice sí
2 x + 3
esto es igual a 9 pues cuánto es 4x
menos 3 y bueno este problema está muy
fácil es un problema con una ecuación en
la cual podemos resolver para x y
después sustituir el valor de x en esta
expresión así que vamos a hacerlo y para
resolver esta ecuación lo que voy a
hacer primero es quitar este 3 de aquí y
para esto voy a restar 3 de ambos lados
de la ecuación aquí menos 3 aquí menos 3
de tal manera que aquí me queda aún más
estos dos se van y me queda que 2x es
igual a 6 y entonces voy a pasar todo
dividiendo entre 2 todo entre 2 y me
queda que x es igual a 3 perfecto y
ahora si sustituyó el valor de 3 en esta
expresión que tengo aquí que me va a
quedar bueno voy a obtener lo siguiente
que 4 por equis pero x vale 3 menos 3 es
el resultado que yo quiero obtener 4 por
3 es 12 menos 3
entonces mi resultado es 9 que por
cierto es el inciso b perfecto ya tengo
el primer problema así que vamos a hacer
aquí también el segundo problema para
ahorrar espacio y dice en un auditorio
hay ocho secciones de asientos entonces
tengo ocho secciones secciones ok y de
estas ocho secciones de asientos cada
sección contiene al menos 150 asientos
pero no más de 200 como podemos poner
eso en matemáticas bueno vamos a decir
que ese es una de estas secciones y esta
sección tiene al menos 150 asientos y
eso lo puedo poner como que 150 es menor
o igual que ese pero no tiene más de 200
asientos por lo tanto puede tener 200
pero no puede tener 201 eso quiere decir
que la cantidad de asientos por sección
está entre los valores de 150 y de 200
ahora me preguntan cuál es los incisos
me dice una cantidad correcta de
asientos que tenga el auditorio es decir
tenemos aquí 5 incisos y cuáles de estos
incisos tienen un valor correcto para la
cantidad de asientos que va a tener el
auditorio y bueno para esto me gustaría
ver primero cuál es la cantidad de
asientos que podría tener el auditorio y
si cada una de las secciones tienen 350
y 200 y tenemos ocho secciones pues las
ocho secciones entre qué valores podemos
tomar con la cantidad de asientos bueno
si te das cuenta de un mínimo que
podrían tomar es que cada una sección es
válida de 150 y como son ocho secciones
entonces tendríamos 150 por 8 150 por 8
cuanto esa pose es lo mismo que 300 por
4 que son 1200 muy bien entonces la
cantidad de asientos está entre 1200 que
sería si cada una de las secciones
tuviera solamente 150 asientos que es lo
mínimo que se puede ahora por otra parte
imagínate que cada una de las secciones
contenga la cantidad máxima que se puede
bueno si cada sección es de entre 150 y
200 la cantidad máxima que puede tener
por sección son 200 pero sí
tenemos ocho secciones entonces podemos
decir que la cantidad total de asientos
están entre 1200 y si todos tuvieran 200
me quedaría 200 por 8 lo cual es 1600
entonces la cantidad de asientos está
entre 1.200 y 1.600 y bueno aquí tenemos
el inciso a el inciso b que son 800 es
no funciona el pse tampoco el te
funciona el d dice que podemos tener
unir 300 asientos y si te das cuenta
1300 está entre 1.200 y 1.600 asientos
por lo tanto nuestra respuesta correcta
es el inciso de muy bien entonces ahora
dejarla borrar la pantalla y déjame
pasar a un nuevo problema así que déjame
borrar la pantalla y déjenme pasar a un
nuevo problema el problema número 3
quien me dice en el problema número 3 y
el problema 3 tiene una nota que dice
tenemos una figura
y tiene la siguiente figura así que
déjame hacer la siguiente figura voy a
tomar este color el color azul cielo me
voy a tomar este y entonces se ve más o
menos así tiene una línea por aquí y
después tiene otra línea
por aquí más o menos como
más o menos como está muy bien y después
tenemos un bonche de puntos así que
déjenme tomar cada uno de los puntos y
tenemos por aquí el punto am
muy bien por aquí tenemos al punto b ok
por acá tenemos el punto ce muy bien por
acá tenemos el punto d y por acá tenemos
al punto
y bueno hasta acá hasta acá tenemos al
punto equis y además dicen que esta
línea se llama l y nos dicen que el
segmento x es perpendicular a la línea l
por lo tanto aquí se forma un ángulo de
90 grados que no me quedó tan mal y
además medición a ciertas medidas me
dicen que de ave hay tres unidades debe
hacer hay dos unidades de shehadeh hay
tres unidades de de ahí hay solamente
una unidad y de cea x hay ocho unidades
muy bien y me preguntan cuál es los
siguientes segmentos que voy a poner
aquí en los incisos tiene una mayor
longitud
y muy primer inciso inciso am que dice
el segmento x a bueno este es mi primer
inciso inciso b dice que es el xvii y
creo que ya se empieza a cumplir un
patrón inciso c es el segmento xc inciso
abc de inciso d es el x de el segmento x
de muy bien y me insisto en el segmento
x
ok ahora a qué segmentos me estoy
refiriendo si te das cuenta x a es este
segmento de aquí xb es este segmento de
aquí es más vamos a dibujarlos si yo me
tomo ahora este color y me voy a tomar
otra vez este de aquí perfecto
quién es mi segmento x a mí segmento que
quizá sería este de aquí perfecto y el
segmento xvii sería este de aquí muy
bien
perfecto
el segmento x pues ya lo sabemos ya lo
tenemos aquí de hecho sabemos que mide 8
y si ahora yo cambio
a ver vamos a ver qué color me ha usado
este de aquí si no me quiero fijar en el
segmento de x pues va a ser este
segmento que tenemos aquí muy bien y el
segmento x va a ser este segmento que
tengo aquí muy bien ahora me preguntan
cuál de estos segmentos es el segmento
que tiene mayor longitud y bueno lo
primero que quiero que te des cuenta es
que no puede ser segmento b x porque el
segmento x es mayor del segmento b x y
la forma de verlo es bueno
de hecho podrás tener un ojo de águila y
ver que realmente este segmento es mucho
más grande que este segmento o la otra
es darte cuenta que por un teorema de
pitágoras tenemos la misma altura sin
embargo la base es distinta la base aquí
vale 2 mientras que la base equivale 5 y
por lo tanto la base es más grande en el
triángulo
x lo que quiere decir que la hipotenusa
va a ser más grande y esto me da pie a
decir que el segmento b x no puede ser
más grande de todos entonces déjame
tacharlo y déjame cambiar a este ahora
con la misma lógica no puedo deshacer de
x de x no va a ser el segmento más
grande porque el segmento x le ganás
note luego luego que el segmento x es
mucho más grande por lo tanto el
segmento de x no puede ser mi respuesta
correcta
además date cuenta que la razón es la
misma usando el teorema de pitágoras
aquí tenemos una base de 4 aquí tenemos
una base de 3 y por lo tanto la
hipotenusa va a ser más grande y x se
hace x es exactamente igual de hecho
esta es la longitud más pequeña por lo
tanto esta tampoco puede ser mi
respuesta ahora me queda x am contra x
sé cómo respondo esta pregunta y la
forma de responder esta pregunta es
fijando en los que tienen la misma
altura y lo que cambia es la base si te
das cuenta aquí tengo un triángulo el
triángulo x
déjame ponerlo de equis a cm y por otra
parte en el triángulo x c
ahora cuál de estos dos triángulos
tienen la hipotenusa más grande y si te
das cuenta la respuesta está en cuál es
la base más grande para el triángulo xcm
tenemos una base de 43 unos 4 mientras
que para el triángulo x c tenemos una
base de 5 por lo tanto a mayor base
mayor hipotenusa y entonces la respuesta
correcta es el inciso a
el segmento x y bueno espero que te haya
gustado este problema y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo donde vamos a resolver
más problemas de este libro